this makeshift school in bangladesh's
krita palong refugee camp may not look
impressive
but it had offered some 600 rohingya
students a chance to learn and dream of
a better future
now it stands empty after local
authorities forced its closure
[Music]
every human has a dream to become
somebody in life education is very
important for it my ambition is to be a
doctor but alas i cannot even pass the
entrance exam here without proper
education
more than nine hundred thousand rohingya
refugees are living in un established
camps
that's after fleeing a military
crackdown in myanmar in 2017.
since then local groups have attempted
to establish private schools
but it's not the first to be closed for
the past three months schools set up in
camps have been shut down by officials
unicef runs schools for children but
they stop at the age of 14.
school shutdown will create a deep
crisis for the children if they can't go
to school they'll get involved in
something bad
a senior member of the government told a
news agency on condition of anonymity
that it's unacceptable to operate a
school without permission
kfori school principal mohammad shawif
says this is not the case
suddenly armed police in charge of camp
security came in and asked whether we
had written permission from the cap in
charge to operate
we told them we had verbal permission
this school was set up several years ago
by our slain leader master mohib ola who
arranged permission everything ran
smoothly until they raided the school
this week
now there's concern for the students
left languishing in the camps
and many wondering why they're not
receiving the basic right of education
laura about a manly al jazeera